we didn't know the extent of the hype
and what it was going to turn into when
we started the movie it got bigger kind
of as we were finishing the movie and
then it got bigger and bigger and bigger
afterwards
[Applause]
i'm not even really here like my body is
here but my brain is like i don't know
where it is i can't i this is like i'm
just like it feels like a kind of dream
like my mind is just avoiding it all so
i'm really quite at ease everybody's so
like awesome and positive and great and
you work so hard on something you're
like so proud of something that this is
like what you do it for so
it's pretty great
kristen stewart in robert pattinson's
careers exploded with the 2008 premiere
of their blockbuster film twilight
that's edward cohen it's totally
gorgeous obviously
don't waste your time
i wasn't planning on it
some fans camped out for two days just
to get a glimpse of bella swan and
edward cullen in real life i think the
fans feel like a real personal
connection to it i understand why the
fans are so hardcore because the book is
just as intense
based on stephanie meyer's novels the
vampire themed romance fantasy quickly
developed a cult following when you get
teenage girls on your side they are very
loyal for a certain amount of time
obsessively loyal they all want to be
part of the club
i think
[Music]
she's a distinct character but
i really could only bring myself to her
i mean she's a very normal girl
and she has very
innate
trust in herself
i could relate to that she's a strong
character she's she's very she's very
powerful in that she's willing to
subject herself to something and give up
the power
we had a lot of stunts because we didn't
have a whole lot of money to have like
big special effects visual effects so a
lot of it was very much we had to pull
it off for real i got to roll around in
some glass and
get like tossed around on a wire
i'm not exactly the best stunt man in
the world
i did as many as i could but i just kept
getting injured all the time you better
hold on tight spider monkey
robert and kristen's chemistry on screen
was undeniable as for offcam at the time
the two said they were just friends
what is it
i don't have
the strength
to stay away from you anymore
and don't
dating rumors revved up in 2009 when the
two were spotted out and about together
outside of work before ultimately
calling it quits in 2012. i just i'm
never going to talk about it and i know
and and it's yeah it's going to continue
to be like why
like you're just you're almost trying to
make it more of a big deal but i'm
actually not because there's no other
way of playing it
they worked hard to keep their real-life
romance cloaked in secrecy regardless
the it pairing led to four additional
movies which have grossed over 3.4
billion dollars worldwide not to mention
a new generation of fans when the saga
hit netflix last summer i saw that it
was on netflix it feels incredibly far
away and also still not that far away
from me on one hand you're like oh i'm
old my god i feel like that was five
minutes ago
now it's like 10-year anniversary it's
rad
[Music]
you